dave portnoy is not a political figure
he's the founder of bar school sports
and a man of deep
common sense and that's why it's to him
we go first tonight
to figure out how should we respond to
this pandemic
great to see you el presidente so you
saw the picture what do you make of it
and what lesson should the rest of us
draw for how we proceed from here
you know the most amazing thing what you
want to question what he's doing is like
if you're going to go break in
quite obviously break your own rules
that everyone's suffering with
how do you let people take pictures of
you how dumb do you have to be to let
people have cameras you need a henchman
to break the cameras if you're going to
be that
you know obnoxious about it like really
seriously
it's insane you know i i i don't think
there's inherently like bad people going
around but
th this i truly believe that the
the government officials who are making
these decisions
if they had a brother or sister there
whose livelihoods were on the line with
a business a small business their
decisions weren't me that
wouldn't be the same and activities like
this you you just reel through a bunch i
remember the philadelphia mayor
and then he's got philadelphia on
lockdown went across the state border
sat down
ate a restaurant um there's endless
examples
and it's so easy to tell other people
what to do with their lives
when you're not directly affected by it
my whole
rant on it my whole passion is small
business
it's the backbone of this country
they've gone through this whole corona
pandemic theoretically to see the light
at the end of the tunnel only to be shut
down again
i'm not going to thanksgiving with my
family tucker whether you know
the corona because it's not worth the
risk for him parents are old
i like my dad my dad's the worst immune
system he'd roll over he won't even put
up a fight
so i'm not going to thanksgiving but
that's my choice that's
our choice as a family and that's what
you have to let people do
we know what corona is and you can
believe the science you can not believe
the size you can think it's dangerous
you cannot
but it's out there and now you have to
let each person each business owner
make the decision if you're old you're
health impaired stay inside
the vaccines are around the corner stay
inside till it's over but
these businesses they're not going to
come back it's already walked through
philadelphia
walked through new york things are
boarded up everywhere
how are they going to survive this what
is going to be left it's a not
have the right to choose your own fate
as a business owner and whether you want
to go out to dinner or not
is crazy in the government officials
don't do it themselves so the whole
thing is really
it's frustrating it's insane
thank you for in injecting a little
perspective uh
into this that's about the most sensible
nonpartisan take i think we're going to
find
on the corona pandemic dave portland
great to see you thank you
thanks for having me tucker